thank you
[Music]
welcome back to care for boys well we
are very careful boys what the [ __ ]
leave it in
the next time uh are you checking the
mics okay just because I'm gonna make
sure Anthony's lit or you want to turn
off Anthony's lights dude I could tick
but okay you want to make sure Tyler
didn't [ __ ] up I could see him right
here it's [ __ ] creepy dude you see
yeah I could see him in the [ __ ]
window
let's go Tyler
hey hey Tyler not bad not bad close the
door all right today we're talking about
we have an update about bart Bart's
parents as everyone knows they got back
together they moved in together there
was romance perhaps some spiciness do
you thinking of spiciness what's the
update you think there's a bunch of
[ __ ] oh gosh well that's what he's
saying right there were some sweaty days
and some hot nights I don't think so uh
AC was broken
my obviously they got divorced long time
ago because they can't get along right
why smiling because it's funny I like
this story it's funny and it's ironic
because before my dad even moved in with
my mom he pitched the idea to me when he
was living with me in Vegas so the
original plan just to catch you up yeah
yeah uh me Gian Taco we moved to Vegas
and uh uh my dad was like oh man you're
so far I want to move to Vegas too and I
was like well I don't even know if I'm
gonna like it here for very long so I
was like let me live here for like maybe
three years get over the honeymoon phase
everything's awesome in the beginning
and if I feel like I'm gonna stick
around then you come because I don't
want to uproot you and your errands and
your like routes when you visit uncle
and all that stuff my dad being the
impatient and kind of like very anxious
guy that he is
um like literally three months later he
was like you know what I don't even want
to live anymore
I just [ __ ] by myself I'm just gonna
die I might as well just commit suicide
he just says all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and
me not really knowing my dad that well
they're quite smiling
um I just kind of took his word for it
and I was like okay well I'm gonna try
to cater it to his needs
so we got him a house in Vegas and uh
Geo actually had a really smart idea she
was like why don't we sell his current
house in L.A at the peak of the market
and then just have him move in and I
know how Geo feels about my family
because my family is extremely annoying
to me so I know usually she's trying to
like protect me from them but then uh
the fact that she was like why don't you
move him in I was like well that's
pretty cool this might be a good chance
to get to know him because I didn't
really get to know him the last 20
something years because they were
divorced since I was six
so he moves in and then I read this is
what I really get to know his super
anxious and like [ __ ] uh emotional
ways where like in whatever state he's
in he can say whatever the [ __ ] he wants
and then later when you when you ask him
about it oh yeah of course I was pissed
so like as a kid he would literally
would be like oh your mother
it's awesome you're my son and all that
and like if he gets physical I should
never have [ __ ] had you get the [ __ ]
out of the house like that kind of [ __ ]
you know so uh when when they call that
yin and yang yeah yeah so yeah so my dad
so I haven't lived my dad now uh there
was a time where we moved uh in July we
during tyco's summer vacation we came to
live with uh Jill's family so if I could
play with his cousins because he has two
other cousins that are exactly the same
age super cute
when I go back he goes you know when I
was just there by myself I felt like I
was in jail it was I don't know if I
could live in Vegas anymore and then I
was like oh man like this this
[ __ ] got my fine if you want to
move back we'll figure out another way
to like get your ass back to L.A even
though I [ __ ] told you don't come
here
for at least three years and he goes I
have an idea your mom's old I'm old I'm
sure we don't want to die alone what if
I go you know like live with your mom
and I'm like I'm pretty sure uh mom
doesn't want anything to [ __ ] do with
you and then he was like oh wait what
yeah he goes how do you know I'm like
because Mom literally like is a woman so
she [ __ ] chats her mouth off all the
[ __ ] time and she can't wait to
gossip all the [ __ ] time can you grab
right there absolutely not and she never
mentions her name once in the 30 however
many years you guys have been broken up
and then he goes and then he hurts my
feelings too and then he's not looking
good and then and then and then also I
told my dad like you know what like uh
in the years that I've like been in
business he's like I still don't get it
right so you're still explaining it and
I was like in all the years because I
could just see the stuff going over my
dad's head and then I was like in all
the years that I've been in business and
like in like you know going YouTube and
all that stuff like I the amount of
people I encounter is much higher
frequency than the average person that
has a nine to five right because we like
we're like going to parties networking
whatever traveling tours all kinds of
[ __ ] so like I see a lot of Dynamics
Even in our in barbell we have people
that are like we have staff that's like
55 like there's like we're encountering
all kinds of different people and I'm
like looking at your personality type
dad and mom's personality type you guys
should have never gotten married to
begin with you guys were [ __ ] horny I
understand that uh maybe during societal
pressures in that age you guys are like
both late bloomers you have to force the
kid out and understand so I hold nothing
against you but you guys made me out of
a mistake and I don't think you should
ever go back to talk to Mom and then all
of that just goes
like that he's like boil it down for me
tell me everything I don't really I'm
not really clear on this I
back and live with your boss so yeah so
this [ __ ] still [ __ ] goes
back goes back and my mom not of the
kindness of her heart she's like you
know what he's all like I'll treat him
like we'll be cohabitants I'll take care
of him and like
um respect him as my son's father but
there's gonna be a [ __ ] hard line of
there's no zero romance you [ __ ] that
up I don't think we're ever gonna so
that's really cool with my mom
and I was like all right it's gonna be
on you but whatever you guys the kind of
beef that you guys get into because I
know it's gonna happen don't [ __ ]
bring me into this and now every every
[ __ ] day since then I've been getting
double texts literally black hey so your
dad doesn't want to uh like he doesn't
want to go to the doctor with me and
then from my dad I'll be like hey your
mom's gonna drag me to the doctor like
[ __ ] every day the same [ __ ] double
text constantly constantly constantly
and I'm like in my head I have like the
biggest I [ __ ] and I told you so
and so now after a few months my mom's I
can't [ __ ] live with this
[ __ ]
um you need to get him out of here and I
was like I [ __ ] knew it this is what
I told my dad I was like you guys are
even you made me out of a mistake and
you want to make this mistake again you
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] and so that's what
we're at now that's where we're at now
so you're weren't a mistake man yeah I
know I was you're more like okay fine
you're a mistake
he Harmony
existed they would have never matched
you know what I mean do you think that
that mistake was missionary doggy style
it my dad probably missionary I saw him
do missionary before like he's lying
down or I I saw him do missionaries
before well my dad had a girlfriend when
I was in high school and actually walked
in on them doing it when I was 15 and I
almost [ __ ] threw up into my [ __ ]
sheets
into your sheets yeah cause I [ __ ]
ran across walking with your blanket
I came home one night I came home one
night and I'm like Dad did you tell your
God
I saw my dad's car and I was like Dad
Dad where are you where are you and
there's nothing and I'm like what the
[ __ ] and then I see his door cracked
open just a little bit so I'm like Dad
are you sleeping I gotta go pick up my
shoes real quick I opened the door and I
see my dad [ __ ] butt naked more like
this
Oh I thought you were dressed up as a
ghost
Halloween he tried to scare him scare
your
father's Dad where are you hey good for
him yeah
just add that to your story next time so
it's your job to get him out of the
house well so now there's the monetary
aspect of things right where like I help
my dad get his house I in front of the
down payment for the house in Vegas but
then he paid it off with the rest of his
money
and so the plan that we had that we all
agreed upon was okay [ __ ] if you finally
made a mistake you want to move back
that's fine what we'll do is we'll take
the house that you bought that you no
longer won't want we'll rent that out
with that income come January I'll find
you a place to rent and then that way
it's like your stupid ass [ __ ]
decisions isn't a financial burden on
anybody okay does that mean he's
coasting at your Mom's till January
that's the thing my mom's like I don't
know if I could take it anymore you
gotta be careful do you know the
holidays make people feel all warm and
fuzzy oh [ __ ] they're gonna be you're
gonna have a mistake bruh mistake
brothers and sisters probably not left
them right you don't know my mom dude my
mom's a [ __ ]
monk like it's hard to get her to even
crack a smile so um yeah so like now my
mom's I can't take it anymore you gotta
get this [ __ ] out of here so now
there's gonna be like this additional
burden where I'm like well [ __ ] do I
gotta like to help my mom do I have to
Fork out rent in La for a mistake that
my dad made which can be like an
additional two G's a month just randomly
that I'm paying when it's something that
I saw [ __ ] well six months ago yeah
you know what I mean and so now I'm like
by by like morals I'm like [ __ ] no you
made your own mistake you better go pay
your own rent but then also because I'm
family and I [ __ ] love my mom I don't
want her to like have to like get all
stressed I'm always like said your dad
moved I lost like 10 pounds and my mom's
already 90 pounds so she's [ __ ] 50
pounds what
she's 55 pounds that um was perfect
margin of error slightly yeah it's like
I'm good at math is there anything your
parents say like you give your advice or
two cents on that they actually take in
into consideration nope
and that doesn't bother you at all does
it
not a single [ __ ] thing man
so your mom's a total monk huh yeah you
think if we had her in hot seat we
couldn't turn her on every single guy in
this room oh God I actually want her
actually I do want to bring her on for
us we should I do want to bring her on
because I don't remember that she's
probably the most interesting person
I've ever met and everyone I've ever
brought her around thinks she's the most
interesting person she's not in a good
way too if she don't break the ice for
us I'm gonna sit here like a little
Asian boy not know how to say anything I
know my age oh she'll Break the Ice Dude
so she used to work at um like a pretty
much like a Fortune 500 company like
[ __ ] a t like a very corporate place
she somehow got all the white people in
there to say Nihao to [ __ ] bow to her
every [ __ ] morning like she got all
the white people like she's a [ __ ]
influencer yeah yeah she got everyone in
the whole [ __ ] Department from one
little tiny Asian lady she's [ __ ]
powerful dude now she's 55 pounds though
yeah you said she's 55 pounds right yeah
but she's getting even stronger you know
yeah what the [ __ ] she is crazy or
chase it through the roof bro that's
like recently what I've been dealing
with because like we had a plan it was
gonna be like help my dad get a place to
rent and then everyone thinks the real
estate Market's gonna crash 2023 so I
was gonna uh help him buy a house then
so that you know just there's just so
many layers to it but then now it's like
everything was through the roof my mom
doesn't like it and then every single
time my mom's like hey you got to get
your dad out here my dad texted me and
he's like hey your mom wants me out of
here and I was like yeah I know so like
you're on a bridge like Spider-Man right
because I know you like Toby Maguire you
like Toby and then and then on on the
one end of the bridge you got your mom
and on the other you got your dad and
you can only save one where are you at
that's not what happened no he was a
train yeah there's also like no Asians
in it that's not the point what do you
mean there's no agent that was half of
anything you can [ __ ] do with it I'm
just saying he's [ __ ] trying to save
a [ __ ] his mom or his dad can we
pretty sure there's an Asian guy in the
background with rubble falling off you
literally just went at his 55 pound
Mount can you just chill for like one
second I actually can't I actually can't
no he's all hyped up now yeah dude he's
[ __ ] he's turned on already I said
you have a choice Steve would probably
give it to her good
that's the thing about bart you can't
even push him it's not even that fun
What's
um what's your choice my choice would be
[ __ ]
but let go both of them save myself
you're not even at risk you're on the
bridge gravity's working in your favor
oh dude have you seen Spiderman let's
just focus on the analogy the concept
we're talking about the training part
where he gets pushed yeah the train part
not the bridge no I'm not I'm not there
who gives a [ __ ] guys it's an analogy
it's a metaphor it's a he's gotta save
one or the other that's all at this
point at this point I'll pick my mom
over my dad easy because I I've been
I've been getting like I've uh beginning
to realize my dad's actually like has
huge narcissistic Tendencies so he
doesn't think about anyone else but
himself so he can't be helped yeah so he
can't be helped because he's still the
victim in every single thing like every
single thing where I'm like wait what if
we do this and we create a situation
because it's like super boiled down it's
my kids leave me I want to kill myself
I'm inside my house okay cool let's move
you to Vegas well now I'm in jail so
everything is some the world is
happening to him constantly so there's
nothing that I can do to help him or
like now your mom's being a [ __ ] to me
I'm like well you're a guest in her home
technically yeah so you need to be on
your best behavior I go to the doctor
when she says go to the doctor yeah like
so it's like it's things constantly
happening to him and he doesn't realize
it's what he's doing so it's really hard
to help someone like that so you got to
remove like the safety net to let him
just figure it out for himself at this
point which is hard to do because his
family he's gonna be like I'm gonna kill
myself
do you think he's beating you up I'm
like here you go here you go don't do it
like there's one in the chamber
he's a great only one
here's all that is 20 more it's an
extendo third person POV you're back on
the bridge but now you're looking at all
of us and all of us are one body and
we're holding your dad on one end and
then we're holding Joe's dad on and you
got to tell us which one to let go
let go of Joe's Dad yeah so after all
that Joe's dad is like the worst Dad I
think Joe's that's worse because Joe's
dad just left the family when he was 13.
um and just bounced because he started
another family and he hasn't really come
back until he needed something
my dad well you got an image of your dad
doing this for like a [ __ ] I know
it's pretty disgusting by the way that
wasn't until Spider-Man either that was
in the back with the Asian guy like my
parents got divorced but my dad really
tried to make an effort to be a dad
and I feel that you know okay yeah so
like I I really I feel that about him
and um did you feel that Neiman Marcus
do you think your dad's such a victim
that he's beating the [ __ ] out of you
with Ethan Allen and he's like oh my
[ __ ] hands hurt
why'd they do it that's my ultimate
narcissism yeah
yeah do that one okay so your uh Andrew
Garfield right and then your dad is
[ __ ] uh what if her face is the Emma
Stone Emma Stone right and then you you
have a chance you know that in the
regular movie
um spoiler alert if she dies whoa holy
[ __ ] I did not see that one damn I
forgot
oh did I [ __ ] this up already no keep up
keep going all right so you dive after
him her your father right and then you
know you know that in the original
script you can let him go but you have
the power to change this moment and save
him what do you do probably let him go
dude
damn
what a payoff what a payoff for
listening you know when you're young
your dad's the [ __ ] superhero right
yeah you're like which superhero
nameor and then the oldest the older
that you get Invisible Man
the older you get the more [ __ ] you
realize so like I remember
um my dad and my my oldest uncle they
were beefing when I was in high school
to the point without yelling at each
other and I guess I don't know what the
true facts are but it has something to
do with my dad helped bring my uncle
here from China
and he told him not to sign up for some
sort of like I don't know insurance or
something because if or to sign up for
it before you get uh medical procedures
done because it's gonna cost in the
hundreds of thousands so my dad's want
to be the sponsor that gets screwed over
something happened anyways my dad thinks
my uh my uncle [ __ ] them over by
starting procedures too early my uncle
didn't think so so they stopped talking
like they don't they're dead to each
other on my grandpa's death bed when I
was 17 in the hospital there's like
seven brothers and sisters they're all
hanging out there and I'm like Hey Dad
on my grandpa's about to die literally
in like five like five minutes do you
want to like in his presence show him
that you guys are cool they looked at
each other and then they were they still
kept that going
so my Grandpa died with those two like
your own like kids not getting along and
so like I still don't know who's right
or wrong but as I get older I start to
go oh wait I can see why there's like
the majority of the siblings all kind of
hang out and you are only cool with only
like one of them because probably his
narcissistic Tendencies he's always the
victim and the one that he is the
coolest one with out of [ __ ] seven
brothers and sisters just so happens to
be the nicest happiest go lucky guy so
that guy is probably just cool with
everything he's not affected as much
yeah he's just not as happy what what
age order is your dad in out of the
seven he's the youngest oh he's the
youngest he's also the baby too oh damn
so the one that's the tightest with them
is the one right older uh a little bit
older than him yeah and then the other
one that I have seen be really really
tight is the oldest sister who is
probably like his mother figure you know
and then and then where's your uncle the
one he's beefing with in that order he's
the the oldest brother
wow so the oldest brother mother and the
youngest have the beef and because you
know I was like that [ __ ] you know what
I mean even in your your grandfather's
death bed I admire how [ __ ] how
stubborn that is yeah
I actually I think that that takes real
that takes that's hard to do because you
guys want to make up [ __ ] no because for
me I was like dude I only wished I had a
brother so I I mean I don't know because
I'm the only child right so I'm like
that's [ __ ] crazy but I guess I've
never been there so I don't understand
but I'm like damn I only wished I had a
brother and I don't think I would ever
like let something get that big where I
where it feels like the parents are
split even when they're on their
deathbed you know who wish she had
Brothers
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man said that in
no way home yeah
yeah because I watched the movie
with the Asian guy what the Asian guy
yeah sure
that's right that's right yeah Doctor
Strange yeah
that's so much you're right
foreign